[Musique]
nounours nous sommes arrivés oui
nounours nous sommes au dessus de chez
tes amis tu ne descend pas les voir on
shore pas trop jurés volontiers leur
rendre visite si cornish attack un peu
plus hauts revenus j'ai trop peur de
trouver un désordre terrible aussi je
préfère lire cet excellent robopolis
au lieu de toi tu m'as fait peur et j'ai
l'impression que juliette a est venu de
chercher ce possible mais je le reprends
allons nounours ne fait pas la mauvaise
tête mes lunettes
jusqu'à mai une note aux clients elle me
les a prises et répartit pas tort que je
t'attrape les ados
popopopop
[Rires]
cocu
bonsoir pas preneur cette ville elle
juliette à ma prime lunettes rôle et moi
à l'eau
[Musique]
non alors cornichons viendront des
selles vilaines bêtes ou est-il encore
celui là je suis dans la crise y est
nous nous
soit ce rambo c'est ton petit déjeuner
que tu prépares quand on est chaud non
c'est pour juillet d'un an elle ne le
mérite pas celle là elle m'a pris mais
lui ne tu t'en fais pas c'est pour jouer
mais je veux qu'elle me les rentes mois
elle te les rendra c'était gentil tient
tout ça
a l'air vraiment très bon
ah oui alors c'est bon
juliette à elle s'est envolée
juillet date à
si je comprends bien
rémunérés sont envolés
je vous avertis solennellement si je ne
retrouve pas tout de suite mais là je
vais me fâcher au merlot c'est pas tant
de bruit tu vas lui faire peur elle
s'est cachée il fouette un lumière et
elle va revenir très bien allez tous
vous coucher j'aiderai mais si demain
elle ne me rends pas bête
ce serait très fâché et je ne vous
parlerai plus tu les auras tes lunettes
on fait leur trophée et on te donnera
demain soir c'est promis bonne nuit il
nous
boloni
dorment ou 8
1/2 bonne nuit nemours ça demain
[Musique]
alors nounours et l une est juge et à me
les rendra demain pas trop c'est une
qu'aucune pourvu qu'elle ne me les
cassent pas ne te fais pas de souci elle
est très soigneuse
allons en route en route bonne nuit de
man
2 pour
[Musique]